si vous êtes ressortissant britannique
vous êtes probablement concerné par ce
qui va suivre en effet en ce jour de
premier anniversaire du brexit de
nouvelles procédures entre-temps vigueur
et notamment pour ceux d'entre vous qui
vivent et veulent continuer à vivre en
France et ils aiment pour qu'ils
comptent récit installé à l'avenir
techniquement depuis ce 1er janvier 2022
c'est cher sujet de ce Majesté doivent
désormais justifier d'un titre de séjour
en tout cas si je compte rester plus de
3 mois sur le territoire français et oui
le Royaume-Uni ayant quitté lui il n'y a
plus de totale liberté de circulation
des personnes entre Lille et les
continents il y a bien eu en 2021 une
période transitoire au cours de laquelle
un passeport suffisait pour résider en
France mais ça désormais c'est terminé
alors comment ça va se passer d'abord
tous les ressortissants britannique ne
sont pas logés à la même enseigne à ceux
qui se sont installés en France avant le
31 décembre 2020 c'est-à-dire avant le
brexit sont éligible à l'obtention d'un
titre portant la mention accord de
retrait cette autorisation de séjour et
5 ou 10 ans selon que le demandeur a
déjà résider plus ou moins longtemps en
France et ceux qui en bénéficie non pas
besoin d'autorisation pour travailler
ensuite il y a les autres arrivé en
France après le brexit donc à partir du
1er janvier 2021 cela il se verront
heureux mettre un titre de séjour
classique dont la durée de validité et
les conditions d'attribution dépendre du
droit commun français en fait comme pour
n'importe quel autre ressortissant
extra-européen et ils doivent demander
l'autorisation de occuper un emploi il y
a bien sûr d'État d'exception
particularité et conditions lister sur
le site du ministère de l'Intérieur et
ses nouvelles mesures vont quand même
concernés beaucoup de monde selon nos
confrères des échos plus de 160.000
demande de titre de séjour ont été
enregistré par les préfectures française
il n'y a par ailleurs pas que la
circulation des personnes entre lui et
le Royaume-Uni qui se complique depuis
ce premier janvier 2022 la circulation
des bien aussi à partir d'aujourd'hui
les importations britannique de
marchandise provenance de l'Union
européenne devront faire l'objet d'une
déclaration douanière systématique on
attend de nouveaux contrôles aux
frontières et de nouvelles règles sauf
qu'apparemment les entreprises elles
sont loin d'être prête alors même que
d'autres formalités doivent entrer en
vigueur au 1er juillet de cette nouvelle
année de quoi mettre à rude épreuve
encore un temps le proverbe y a le
flegme de nos voisins d'outre-Manche